you're talking about iggy azalea
and what was it playboy mccarty played
with cardi yeah
wait wasn't there some old tweet he had
where he was like shooting a shot at
iggy azalea like before he was anything
and it worked out
clearly got a little baby out of the
deal they got up there
but yeah just born right yeah yeah fresh
born
yeah damn he missed the birth of the
child
he did he's playing playstation with uh
little uzi yeah i wonder what gamer they
was playing
what i don't know man trash yeah just
now that is trash
[ __ ] yeah i'm trying to get out how
was uh christmas break fellas i feel
like you haven't seen everybody in a
long time
no right it feels like a really long
time yeah what you do even though our
last recording was what wednesday
and christmas was last wednesday
christmas dude so should we got two
young kids
those that christmas break when no
school nothing
it's i've been gone for two years
parenting huh ooh it's a beast man with
no school it's beastie oh it is
beasty yeah beasty what they ran your
24-hour watch
yeah it's just a lot like non-stop
because usually you get a break either
go to school
or you can especially with coven like
dumb ass shutting everything back down
so it's like
you can't go to restaurants there's no
malls no movie theaters
just like we got you creative a little
homeboy dude i was at riverside they
chilling
riverside's they're not l.a county
district oh gotta get outside of it
they're chilling bro
they were like [ __ ] i guess their uh
sheriff like released the video saying
he's not gonna
he's like [ __ ] that no but you want to
do your everyone but la county's like
listen businesses have been through
enough stay open if you want
yeah it's up to the people to decide if
they're going to shop or not exactly
that's exactly how america is so crazy
yes yeah i was i was album riverside uh
yeah just yesterday what were you doing
out there
my best friend was out there oh the
tommy yeah
the gay boy yeah yeah he looks out there
yeah i love how he says well that's how
that's how i know him
guys you got the hat for
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah
there's there's chilling out there bro
you're just out there chilling with them
mm-hmm what'd you guys my girl and i
went out there
we just had dinner too you went to a
restaurant uh no we ordered
oh we no we didn't feel like going out
right now but you could have went to a
restaurant you should have one
water inside yeah that's some [ __ ]
is it really
[ __ ] yeah we can't eat our restaurant i
picked it up
i was about to say we could do that here
yeah what did you do for christmas just
you and your girl
uh me my my girl white mike his girl
we just chilled out the crib man made uh
white mike cooked up some steaks can he
cook he did good
it was his first time doing it oh he's
not a cook not really
true but white mike did it yeah he did
his thing yeah yeah it's pretty easy
we watch seoul come on man that's what
we do we like it
bro it's deep it's it's i like that it's
good
yeah you watched it i watched it yeah i
watched seoul with my son
and then we watched uh wonder woman 1980
i didn't want to watch wonder woman
patty jenkins is a friend so i'm
you know is that bad
listen unless it's spider-man batman i'm
not a superhero guy
i'm not at all oh really yeah so it's
like but
wonder woman like oh never mind she's
superhero you know my girl loves wonder
woman
loves it uh-huh and even for this one
she's like man it's not
what's that bad actress name who plays
uh wonder woman i forget her name she's
not a bad actress i'm talking about like
yeah she's hot oh bad
oh that was like she's super bad yeah
yeah well you know what it's funny
jimmy burke's in it remember jimmy burke
bryant really brian's best friend
he's in the opening scene unless you
know him you're gonna miss it but he's
in it
yeah she's so gorgeous she's from israel
yeah
yeah right yeah yeah she's super batty
it's always hard to find a picture of
him
yeah he's in the opening scene though um
um but yeah uh so you guys watch that
yeah and just chill then we have four
adult eating steak watching cartoons
yeah
cartoons chris what kind of state dwight
might get you
was it new york troops all right yeah i
mean
with new york strips not really really
not not tender enough for me
i like i like those are my favorite
really you don't like i love new york's
my favorite and then uh a rib eye well
they're only my favorite because
i can i don't i cook those the best oh
you can cook too
mm-hmm you took uh you took a picture we
have the steaks the grilling is
different than cooking your boy here's
grilled milk
if i say well i do i do steaks on a cast
iron yeah
which is great which is cool that's how
most restaurants do it too
yeah butter when they get off yeah yeah
steakhouse stops bro i i can't cook that
[ __ ] no more though
like everyone's like where should i fell
where you been where you been i'm like
bro
i was cooking all bad [ __ ] i learned how
to cook and i just
[ __ ] but you started eating steak on
the diet and stuff
yeah but the way i was making it is
probably not the best way yeah you know
that butter and like just if you did
keto you could do it though
i don't i'm not doing the keto thing you
just i'm just trying to yeah
i don't need your guys's [ __ ]
harassment
so i texted you i went off the group
chat can i
be honest with y'all i gotta tell you
something first what you cheated
bro i had uh i had prince street pizza
again
with your girl that same that same night
oh damn you know how we had it that that
day
i had it again what i even text cat you
want
to wait is this the line
he was texting me like okay i just want
to make sure how do you get the pizzas
i'm getting it for a friend i told them
how to get it
and i told them like how you know you're
fat you don't have to lie to me i'm not
here to judge you
if you want it yeah i got a friend ten
minutes later
he calls me and then he's like cat uh
i'm here there's like a
line that do i wait here and then like i
pick it up and then
i'm getting over my friend so and so i
was like chappelle again dude
you're in the right line you don't have
to lie to me making sure
you got the pepperoni again come on did
your girl like it it wasn't for my girl
it was me my homie that guy
did white mike get it because he was
actually white michael white mike showed
me a picture of it
yeah he got it because he sent me a
picture i said say less and i sent a
picture of me eating it
all right what no white mike got it for
himself yeah yeah
he knows food he knows food yeah he's
really good
he sent me a picture he's like you
should try this place it looks so good
oh there's another
it's called bootleg yeah boot like yeah
it's a bootlegger uh yeah
it's bootleg and they have a food truck
so we're trying to that's what it is
we're trying to line up for my food
truck show oh you just gonna do that
without me well you're lucky i'm on a
diet
well that's the problem with food truck
there's no healthy food trucks coming
too but you don't do it every day no
that's once every two weeks
yeah see then you're good still but
still dude last night the cravings
isn't it should i get past the first
week like i want sugar so bad
yeah last night i like the theme we
finished uh season five
yeah we finished season five of uh love
island straight up best
reality tv i've ever seen in my life
he's loving it fan [ __ ] tastic
were you a kardashian fan no you didn't
watch this show
cause it's too scripted it's not real oh
love island's real
but that um real as [ __ ] that's real
love man
so uh we moved on to season six we're
halfway through
season six but my my pl what i do with
my routine was i get whiskey i pour a
double shot of whiskey and ice
then i have my snackies and my violin
dude which they loaded you up with
whiskey oh
oh that's all i got that's how i know
you're getting older dude all i got was
whiskey
i don't but i'm like oh cool another
bottle of whiskey yeah
i got what you like the guy were two
like cool that's cool this is how you
know you're getting old
there's a mistake you went all out for
gifts and they just give you a bottle of
whiskey
well you you have a fast metabolism yeah
yeah yeah so like
that's why he's skinny you don't eat
like i'm in the gym do you eat crazy
well when i work out i'm starting you're
not the only ones that work out i'm
working out
so i'm eating three four times a day now
healthy or no you just are you trying to
put on weight i'm putting
away you're trying to put on weight then
what'd you do for christmas you went
silent on the group chat
yeah you went very silently i apologize
it's uncomfortable and don't say that
now i was laughing at everything okay i
was laughing at everyone's texts okay i
was trying to be involved
hey listen so um i get home from my
birthday thank you all again for that uh
my queen surprised me with a happy
birthday dinner
and she borrowed what was the dinner it
was uh my favorite uh
turkey lasagna turkey lasagna carry on
okay so um she surprised me after my
favorite
dinner that i like with sprinkle
cupcakes and then she breaks she drags
out this 65-ish tv are you [ __ ]
she brought me a 65-inch tv because she
knows my tv is small
and she was like no upgrade july you
have a real small tv yeah it's kind of
like this one
yeah so she was like that six five
inches 65 inch and not only did she did
you bring it back to the crib
yeah no well i had uh i needed help so i
ubered
because it's so big you know it's not
gonna fit in the center no yeah okay so
the uber had to follow the uber to bring
me to the crib
but not only did she not give me a
65-inch tv charleston bought me my
favorite shoes
what shoes she bought me these air force
ones the uh uh off-white ones
uh these no i got those the black
the black girl you did that tell your
girl you get off my
nuts hold on he said oh you i don't like
how you do this
little things you mean these old things
god damn right now for a hot second
these old things you have a plug brenden
okay she went on her way
and literally like went on the original
with stockx and bought me the shoes the
north carolina or black ones
the black ones oh those are dope i love
those you know you know it's so hard to
get
all black it's like the black with a
silver swoosh yes and then they have the
off-white
really in white on the side would i like
them you would love them you'll love
them
for real yeah can you pull up what they
look like air force one
whites they'll be the first ones usually
people have those or the north carolina
blue ones
these white ones you gotta be careful
when you wear them because that that
bottom turned yellow on you now
i got got my turmeric yeah which one
whoa the black ones the black ones right
there yeah
those blue ones are nice too yeah the
blue ones wow those are really nice and
she got it i was like damn
those are expensive yeah yeah yeah she
won't stop it yeah yeah damn your six
figure queen got you a six five inch tv
i posted a i posted a group chat and
y'all was like okay i'll see you yeah
and i said sell that tv and buy a new
car
it was so messed up when he said jay
said that's rude
i said it's rude but it's true but he
was like sell that car i was like all
right and then my family we all
got each other gifts we got all got each
other money right but we're gamblers
so we got each other money and we crap
and we was playing bingo
i lost my christmas gift yeah we did
secret santa where it's like you can't
spend over 200
you know so yeah uh gift card from
nordstrom or some [ __ ]
i'm getting older dude i was like yeah
cool gift card from nordstrom's thank
you
thank you my girl did it she did the
damn thing she got me a record player
i've been wanting a record player dude
oh really yeah do you have a bunch of
vitals
not yet that's going to be my next
addiction i just know it vinyls yeah
that's a dope
uh band t-shirts and uh finals will be
my [ __ ] next oh there it is yeah
that's a grateful dead
yeah i was a thousand dollars no i don't
know
oh you know oh you didn't buy it yeah i
bought it or yeah no one gave me this
all right i wish i got it
i don't know yeah what do you what would
you want no
no clue nothing you know someone could
be clever and get you something we
should have done that
[ __ ] we [ __ ] no i'm [ __ ] up don't
worry
don't worry yeah don't worry we got them
something what's happening
oh by the way real quick uh thank you so
much people don't know what brenda's
brandon gave us all a bonus
oh yeah oh yeah yeah pops to you no i
don't even know if it went through or
not yeah
just curious did your bones go through
and chin goes
he looks yeah man i went through
all right i'll see you later man you on
great
job [ __ ] no no one said no no
we said thank you but we didn't let him
know that no
so i was like yeah maybe didn't go
through i don't want to bring it up
and then when i went oh you left on
wednesday i went hn
it was so bad she
that's so funny because when it hit i
was like bro thank you britney i said it
i didn't text you
oh it really hit you thank you well
thank you brandon
too late now too late now you didn't
[ __ ] up you're [ __ ] up
wednesday but when we get back from uh
palm beach florida tickets are available
thursday friday saturday palm beach
florida
uh when we get back into it on monday
we'll have an all new set
for real they start building the set
wednesday once we're done i'll show you
the rendering it's [ __ ] dope
damn it's gonna look completely
different all right it's me like a green
room vibe
you know it's gonna be dope okay no more
red
no more red it's gonna be dope okay i
never wear red
you're blending into the [ __ ] chair
but i don't like wearing red at all
uh cause your daddy's a [ __ ] why does
everyone think he was a [ __ ] was he not
he wasn't blue no it's just the color of
the [ __ ]
well what color is an outfit what color
what color did his gang wear
uh i think it was i think they had i
think it was just black
he was a black disciple no i don't know
what i don't know
didn't have don't kiddings have certain
colors so you know like who not to shoot
that's what it's like it's like football
wait hold on blue
red black yellow i've never actually
like the lightning kings are yellow and
black cool thing though my dad got his
uh rights back
oh that's cool so he can vote down she
can vote now he can do all that [ __ ]
i think he i think he can get a gun now
he wasn't not get carried away i think
he can he can vote
he can vote no he no cause he said he he
was pretty much everything you could do
i can do
damn that's the guy yeah that's great
cat how was your uh
christmas holiday it was cool i spent it
with my sister and stevie and for 24
hours we did nothing but watch love
island season five
yes season five my sister is hooked on
it yeah
uh i wanna say a spoiler in three two
one did
you cried when that thing with amy
happened my sister started
balling it's so
are like the relationship like they're
the staple of the house
from day one so they're yeah like
they're
you're like oh like i used to tell my
girl
uh curtis and amy and then tommy and
molly mam like they just need to leave
they found love get the [ __ ] out
like bring in new [ __ ] yeah
you realize why the producers don't kick
them out because
probably halfway through curtis is like
man i'm starting to have other feelings
for other girls
and he tells one girl that he likes her
you're like what the [ __ ]
so then uh he tells another girl that he
likes her
so then amy curtis basically break up
but they're still in the house and you
it comes out of left field
she's like hey i need everyone to gather
around the fire pit you're like what's
this [ __ ] gonna say like whatever
and she's like i'm leaving she's like
i'm out and she's
and she her and curtis have this
one-on-one dude my eyes started to fill
up i'm like i am not crying over reality
show
looking like my girl tears tears
and she's just like you know we are
friends we start off as friends you know
and
you're not gonna be able to move on
unless i leave yeah so i'm leaving your
girl loves it huh
oh dude so into it but now she can't get
over like
like that season five is so [ __ ] good
and you care so much about everybody on
the show
now we start season six we're like
halfway through
it's just not like getting fake right
look at it
what are you saying what she was like
i'm leaving
but you don't know why how far are you i
am episode
i think it was like 43 or something okay
so they
so they went to the other where they go
to the casa
whatever yeah way past that i'm like
yeah and so and then
michael and michael gets with homegirl
yeah
at the part where like he said like he
has feeling for her and then like he
dipped
it's because then michael michael and uh
what's her name
uh amber michael and amber are also a
super close couple
and what they do on the i don't know if
you're this far like in the middle of
the show
they send the guys to an all girl's
house and the girls in all boys house
the guy stayed at the same house they
make a connection yeah with somebody
else
and michael who's with amber and they
don't know if they're gonna switch or
not
they find out as they're walking through
the door with another girl another guy
and you're like there's no way michael's
going to switch this [ __ ] dude
switched
do you think these producers are letting
them feel they do that on purpose do
they induce it
i think no i i think they they what
happens
you know i know one of the producers i
think they text them like hey
go ask michael how he feels about this
girl or go out they just do that
yeah but i don't think they're like hey
make sure you switch and but the the
the the curveballs and the switcheroos
on this show where it's [ __ ]
because there's so many everything crazy
yeah so many episodes
and they get so famous that show's so
big in the uk do they have sex
yo yeah oh dude buy the bike you're on
season are you going yeah yeah
uh two couples have sex dude
oh by by the end of it all everybody all
the sheets are like this
everybody everybody's [ __ ] everybody
honestly
why put the sheets on yeah
here's the thing i would pay a premium
i'd pay a hundred dollars a month if
there was a
uh love island black you know what i'm
saying where it's just
an extra few bucks and i get to watch
them [ __ ]
like educated like extra dude
love island would be so dope how long
they could pick you i would i would also
reach it you could pick this
this is for first 48 uh i think it's on
a e
i'd also pay an extra premium if you'd
show me the dead bodies
don't blur it out show me the dead body
you want to pay a
premium for that you're right you want
to see it you're right yeah i want to
see this
oh they do show it actually bro yeah
yeah i want to see the dead bodies you
want to see it yeah i won't see all the
murder scene oh i like that [ __ ] hey you
like that [ __ ] i got really good you're
a white mic bro every time he turns on
like one of them
i go i go to my room i don't like it i
walk the [ __ ] out some i like when it's
older [ __ ] i like the newer no this is
like michael he watched like the older i
got really into the black dahlia lately
do you know that
super um uh murder in los angeles
yeah they thought they found this
woman's body uh
you can go and they don't know who they
still don't know that killer yeah yeah
it's a cold case i mean super it's like
in 19 was she an actress 1947 she wasn't
but her body was found the uh malik
it's separated yeah you bring up the
murder picture
that's her right there and and they cut
her she died by this
they cut her uh from uh lip to air to
cut
like the joker they call it a glasgow uh
smile
glass guy yeah glass glass girl there's
a famous soap
so the blanket has that uh scar yeah
so the blankets over the body but
there's pic you can find the picture
where it's removed and so her body is
separated
so her upper and lower separated like
how you do a magic trick yes
okay and the body was drained of all
this blood
and they said for someone to do this
like it had to be like something like a
doctor someone who's really good with a
knife
because they knew exactly where to cut
everything where is it when you cut her
nipples off they cut her breast off well
not the two cut her mouth
she yeah what's the back story why
they don't they don't know but with the
but the the podcast wants to
i'm listening to now in the black dahlia
is uh
once world war ii was over and all the
troops came back
murder especially in la all over the
country but especially in la went
through the roof
with women like a lot of women were
murdered really
and they don't know if it was like a
serial kill because at the time the
the term serial killer wasn't there it
wasn't a thing
they never put it all together so they
know if it's copycat or if it's one guy
killing all these women like a bunch of
women died in l.a
the same way cut to the mouth through
the mouth
horrible chin out there clearing that
browsing yeah yeah
any memory of that black dolly it's
super interesting there's a movie
i think nicole kidman there's uh the
dude from uh hogan's heroes
yeah remember that actor that was that
was a crazy one too
his was something with like his was like
pretty [ __ ] up too
oh [ __ ] black dolly is crazy though
cause she and then she would call the
mom and be like
you know out she came to la to be in
movies she was like oh i'm getting
this role i'm starting this this and she
wasn't doing anything
she was like she was like she had a
bunch of boyfriends like [ __ ] around
a lot she got caught up in a lifestyle
okay gotcha yeah
uh bob crane
his like death scene was pretty
oh i see that scottsdale look at the
girl in the back
girl in the back yeah with this laying
down no i think
that bed on the yeah that right there
you see that is that him
that's a girl that's a girl yeah
yeah but you say you will pitch first 48
just show me the body so i don't know
what i'm working a premium
and also hulu i will pay a
whole lot of money to get that those
x-rated sex scenes
oh i love island yes love island only
fans love island only it'd be
so dope i i think
i kind of you really are you off the
deep end right now
i love it all right i started looking
about property where the house is at you
can rent you can oh yeah yeah
where is it located uh season five four
and
three are filmed at a island right
outside of spain
it's a beast to get there so you gotta
fly into spain
and take a three-hour boat ride to the
island three hours yeah that's what
usually happens when you go to these
islands but then
but then season six is new it's in south
africa and it looks
so hot and the crickets are so loud like
at night you know when they're like
talking wait what's season's in south
africa six six it's a new season
no that's what we know that's the one we
know yeah that's when
all of us started watching together oh
and i'm i'm way beyond that
right yeah yeah
hey hey guys did you know you use a
water bottle no
only stevie responded i know he turned
over and showed me like isn't this cool
yeah yeah i got one for me my girl with
our names on it and [ __ ] i can't wait
for it to come in
[ __ ] doors
when i saw that that's why i was like
yeah what the [ __ ] is it doing
i love it are you gonna get the mic as
well the mic
yeah wait what did it go a little more
necklaces yeah oh god i got it yeah
you gonna get that but steve steve was
right he's like dude i can't believe i'm
so in this show where they do
they don't do anything they don't do
anything they're still on a paddock it
must suck they're in that house for 12
weeks
they can only leave on saturdays and
they can only be gone for like three
hours and they come back
they have no communication with the
outside world for 12. like i was on the
ultimate fighter for six weeks
but i know six weeks it's a beast you
just want to cry and [ __ ] yeah you're
just like dude
i want the real world man i don't know
imagine what being on season six spoiler
alert in three
two one there's a white boy on there and
he's a he's a lord
so he's royalty in england yeah yeah
he lifts out episode four he just leaves
yeah he leaves he's like man i think
he's above that he's a little like
i think i'm in love with my
ex-girlfriend and it's just
i feel like it's fake if i'm here
searching for love when i love this girl
so i looked it up
dude he laughed and got back with
they're together they live together
right now
right now yeah his ex yeah that's what
he took him back that's why i love
consistency how dope is that i love his
tonight love is
love i love his gangster how dope is
that that is [ __ ] dope yeah
it makes you want to tear up but i'm not
going to chris that's season 6 0
compared to season 5
even the girls and the guys they're just
i mean out of all the contestants
that's the that's the best we got yeah
they look like
trolls compared to season five man like
step the game up dude you can work hard
for season
five what about the twins do you have
have you watched it with your girl
because i told my girl i went oh
season six dope these hottest twins come
about
i [ __ ] up because the twins come out
my girl's like you think they're hot
i'm like well not like you said the same
thing yeah is that what you
said the same thing he was like what i
was like i was like not
hot i mean you know what i'm saying but
that was the first i got hooked that was
the first thing i watched i was like god
damn
we're in boise surrounding this big
house
so of course i was feeding i'm like god
brothers
i get home but then that one girl you
know the one girl i said has has stone
cold steve austin legs
yeah i looked it up she has a condition
oh
yeah apparently a bunch of doctors were
watching love island noticed
that her legs were unproportionate to
her upper half and start diagnosing her
so when she got out of the villa they a
bunch of dms came her way saying like
you need to get checked she went to a
doctor they found out she had a
condition that's why her oh my god
for the listeners i don't mean like
you're like oh her legs are kind of big
i mean you're like what the [ __ ] is
going on she's very fit from like the
waist yeah it looks like she works out
and everything
her lower half is a little off limp
she had to have a bunch of exaggerated
from her
is a disorder characterized by hormonal
hereditary influences
symptoms pain almost exclusively in
women
really oh so she's like
she's in pain and i don't mean like
but she probably didn't even know it she
was just like yeah or she probably just
thought like oh maybe it's
just how legs were everybody's legs like
this yeah can they fix it
they uh took fat out of her lower body
she looks
so much better now and i don't mean like
when you watch show you're like oh yeah
her legs are kind of big no
next to the girls you're like what the
[ __ ] is like it looks like elephant legs
they're so thick so big yeah that's what
stood out to me i'm like yo why
she's had a lot of work that what's
you'll notice too every girl that gets
off the show
they must read through comments and they
get so
insecure because they get so much work
done like have you seen molly may now
i have not that girl that's unfortunate
that you get off like a reality show and
that's all you need molly
molly the one with tommy fury tommy fury
from the box oh i was thinking about
this
they finished second oh she's bad i
remember her
god well she didn't get her now look on
the look on the left
well ain't nothing wrong she got her jaw
done she got a nose you get your jaw
done oh yeah
i have a cousin who got uh his jaw done
he got it chiseled so it's more like
because he had kind of like a square
head
and so like he wanted like the k-pop
kind of like longer
angular length wait is that all the time
no you can also get the fat are you
talking chin or
no botox so it does make her face a
little slimmer yeah because you know the
muscles
that you chew with the masseter it just
it just makes it not or just makes it
stop that's too exhausting i want to see
look at her face in the middle there
though
like the fans were lighting her up
really there's nothing wrong with that
lady
there's nothing wrong i don't think so
like she's gorgeous on the left
there's nothing wrong with her but they
must read the comments
because so many of them get plastic
surgery when they get off
damn so many yeah i'ma just chill with
my face dog
that's wild too to come out of a reality
tv show then you have millions of
followers just randomly it happens
overnight and then just
lighten you up like that's basically why
that the the host committed suicide
oh yeah she was getting so much [ __ ]
online because
the the original host yeah so it's not
that blonde lady
no that's a new one season six was the
new host everything
before that i believe was the old host
yes what was the way
why she was like awards and [ __ ] too
why'd she commit suicide she was talking
too much
nah well she was like the in europe like
the press in like london say they killed
princess diana
but um the press out there is like so
intense so like she she uh
got a fight with her boyfriend and hit
him over the head
and he called the police and he's
pressing charges so she was just getting
so much [ __ ] for that
it's like so much [ __ ] she ended up
hanging herself isn't megan mark
uh what's her name meghan markle yeah
does she get like a lot of hate uh she
gets a lot of hate yeah she's like
prince harry's wife i believe the uh
actress
from the us the half black that have
black girl she's a baddie yeah she's bad
i don't know what that is are you
serious all over the news yeah she is
she gets a lot of
you've never seen her or no but no i
don't know
before this she's she's like the queen
right
uh oh no she's not a queen oh no she's
not so so what happened
no no no they got a divorce the the
other the other one is okay oh gotcha
no it's just uh moved up an american
royalties
they left they didn't do like all the
duties and they're gonna actually move
to canada
i think she's never happened before why
she's just getting a lot of hate
she's an actress she's getting hate
cause she's an actress she's an actress
she's american a lot of people
didn't like her because she didn't like
kind of
she wasn't like the ideal person for
prince harry to marry
and by not ideal she's half black thank
you so like
in england in royalty and no one's black
it's a lord no yeah because you watch
game of thrones queen elizabeth people
something queen elizabeth is conspiracy
they think she's the most powerful
person on the planet
who queens queen elizabeth like that
royal family like it oh yeah
they say some [ __ ] about that i've heard
that but i didn't know i didn't know
um homie and his wife were they did they
dipped out they're like we don't want to
deal with any of this and they're i
think they were moved to canada so they
didn't [ __ ] with the royal t-shirt no no
no no
they're doing that i love
think about it did i say that out loud
yeah no they did but i mean
the the press killed them because she
was trying to get away
the press was like bombarding the she
told the drug
that's when i first heard about
paparazzi
and i thought for the last time i
thought it was like some racist [ __ ] oh
you thought yeah
i don't know i was a kid i brought you
out there when she died i was so
young i was what do you mean like it's
worse than tmz like of course but
they're just like here there's some
rules out there it's pretty ruthless
they can literally like sit
in your lawn your grass all day and just
like yo wait till you come out and say
in london yeah there's no rules you
can't
press charges or anything what are you
gonna do you know and look
why you said it like that like i don't
know what you're gonna do yeah
price of fame okay well that [ __ ] yeah
but anyway
justin bieber almost getting a fight
with one he's getting a fight that's why
he jumped out of that car a lot a lot of
them flip out on those
people yeah kanye did you broke his
camera yeah kanye is the worst you've
seen kanye when he got a studio
and one of the uh pop rides so he's like
yo i need a ride man
you gotta ride from him around yeah he's
like we give me a ride home he's like
sure he jumped in the front seat you've
never seen that
nobody said no no yeah because he was
like what are you doing
i'm trying to get a [ __ ] uber he's
like i'll give you a ride he's like you
hit me right he's like yeah man so he
jumps in the front seat
that is home or some [ __ ] [ __ ] uber
to get a ride from the paparazzi
you can't get a rhyme type movement
tight move
what car did old boy have how's the
superstar today
looking great man
[Music]
he said i'm uh looking for my uber
it's four minutes long
he has to be in beverly hills
[Music]
i don't care what they call me yeah see
the ubers i'm around the [ __ ]
y'all like that term the pops
you take that as like i don't care what
they call me
they're not paying me
wait so he got in the car with the
paparazzi oh he did
yeah his uber just wasn't coming oh all
right
laura right harley passing celebrity
trainer
yes i know where it is he's gonna ride
to the gym
look at that traffic yeah you're working
out
he had a little scuffle right yeah yeah
were you were you there today
no but he's just getting around he's
just chillin
hit or miss right depending on
medications they come with you like that
no they'll say no to you
la's like [ __ ] with the real
celebrities you're right they're coming
after
other people coming after tom cruise
hey so brendan we heard you
when connor's fighting if i'm like at
starbucks or if i might get the grove or
something to come up to me
all right so what do you think connor
i'm like [ __ ] oh
now y'all want to talk to me yeah damn
that's speaking of connor
uh he fights next month right in january
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah so you said you said uh he's gonna
win easy i bet
theo i think two grand yeah they brought
two grand yeah oh because destiny is
from my louisiana they're boys yeah i
gotta
go dustin's my boy too but you know i
gotta ride with hometown
i'm going with destin you riding with
hometown yeah
put some money on it i mean i'll make
quick bank on this you're kind of
confident bro
yes i'll bet my dustin's my boy it's not
it's nothing against dusting but if you
want to bet what do you
bet the bonus i bet the bonus you gave
me oh you want better grand yeah
that's better whoa i mean i feel like i
feel confident
i mean you better tell your six figure
queen to have my [ __ ] cash
that monday she better have cash wait
wait wait hold on now are you confident
for real for
uh tell me why connor's a special dude
he hasn't spot in what two years right
no yeah he hasn't found quite some time
that's important you know he fought last
year he fought uh
dawn cerrone oh did he knock him out
oh wait didn't that that's the elbow
right did he hit him with like some
elbow stuff
or something like that oh shoulder hit
the shoulder oh yeah that's why i was
trying to do that on the street didn't
work
um so so my thing is if
if conor like is 100 on board to get his
title back and he's like in full shape
focused and connor comes and he's out of
10 and dustin poirier comes and he's out
of 10.
connor beats him easy uh it's a good
matchup for him
okay all right but like if conor's at
like an eight he's gonna lose
if he doesn't want to win if he's in
there just for a payday he'll lose
but has connor ever fought like that for
a payday besides floyd yeah
okay okay he gives us all yes i mean he
did
when he fought khabib he wasn't at 100
and he still did the best
anybody's ever done what do you mean he
wasn't at 100 didn't do a full training
camp
kind of half-assed in it because that's
i think
that was that that was after floyd
mayweather correct he had all that money
mm-hmm
damn so you that is whiskey 100 you
think he would actually have like a
a shot be good fight oh really great
fight because he's the only one
to get up on khabib he's the only one to
really beat khabib for a round like he
did well
and like at the time everybody [ __ ] on
conor they're like oh dude blah blah
blah
but then when you see how khabib
dominates everybody yeah you're like oh
[ __ ] god actually did pretty well
damn if you go back and watch fight
you're like damn you didn't do terrible
they did it and then you talked to
anybody from his camp
anybody i talked to dylan danis his
coaches are like yeah dude
you barely trained for that fight why
would he do that's the biggest fight in
his life
just that money man dude yeah it's tough
to [ __ ] get punched in the face when
you got
150 million dollars in the bank right
yeah i remember uh i forget about [ __ ]
a thousand dollars in the bank as i'll
see you
i'm gonna tell these big jokes you're
you're pretty broke
broke yeah damn like would you drive a
sentra
what no don't don't look at him i had a
priest yeah oh yeah you gotta breathe
it's spacious
and i heard about him out here out there
[ __ ]
yo wait time i just wait oh yeah
you go ahead you 6-4
well because i was driving i needed a
car uh with good gas because well chin
drives the prince he's 6-4 one of the
best cars i've ever had
i [ __ ] hate them but the thing is
i i would wake up and kick the car let
me go
because i didn't look at it because i
heard that's how you started yeah yeah
and the thing's so slow
but i needed it because i because i
would for training
every day monday through friday i'd
drive down to orange county to train
where were you living at the time i was
living in venice and i drive all the way
down orange county that's a mission lake
forest
take me two hours train for two hours
drive back so wait oh so when you quit
the ufc you lived here
oh yeah got it yeah i lived here for
four years got it
for oh for four years already yeah and
what and what
and this is like how many years ago six
six years ago and you're you you wasn't
like five
five and you didn't do you you quit ufc
correct yeah
okay so yeah so then but you were still
training you were still training
when i was when i drive to orange county
and stuff like oh yeah oh okay yeah so
you still get are you still
yeah moving around yeah damn in a prius
and no money
living in california yep better running
that on stand-up and podcasting
damn thousand dollars he's like see ya
yeah callum lent me the money for the
first merch yeah and then i was like i
just need this much money to order this
many shirts yeah he's alright cool
he gave me the money for it the shirt
sold out and i was like dude we got
but you know we put in two grand we got
like five grand back i was like oh
here's your money he's like keep it man
put do what you want with it so i just
kept investing in merch
and it was making money off merch yeah
and this is like early
fighting the kids yeah super early damn
damn dog
then what i would do is instead of
getting sponsor money
you know the ufc back then you didn't
have to wear reebok you'd wear whatever
sponsor you wanted
yeah so instead of taking money for the
sponsor shirt i'd wear fire in the kids
shirts
when i'd walk out to the ring oh so i'd
wear like avid kitty fight club sorry
that was that bad that i didn't know
that i was just investing in
myself yeah so i'd wear that shirt and
the next dad have that shirt for sale
and you have the ab and kitty fight club
shirts and then sell out absolutely
why did they get rid of the sponsors in
ufc is just to reebok
reebok they came in reebok was like he
would pay this much money to be the
exclusive sponsor
that was ultimately the ultimate one of
the reasons that pushed me away
because i was a guy making six figures
off sponsors shout out to my queen
and then six figures off sponsors
and then the ufc made a rule with reebok
and so it went from me making you know
mid six figures to
10 grand so i was like god [ __ ] this
damn what that's a huge gap guys
guys he ran a fight yeah bro hell no
no you get punched in the face bro worth
it
oh my gosh yeah bro yeah
yeah ufc he's ruthless yeah he's crazy
that's [ __ ] ruthless
crazy and out here so how long do you
have that prius for though
i signed a three year not so lease
i [ __ ] hate it that's why i hate it
like
i hate electric cars
i burn fossil fuel like a [ __ ]
whatever man through your
oh dude i can't wait to get rid of it
what you so you stole
it uh i just turned it back in the
toyota
yeah y'all keep feeling like you want
another one like [ __ ]
it you want another [ __ ]
[Laughter]
no hell no no i don't have that money oh
i bought like a standard porsche
porsche what what's the standard porsche
411 career
uh you probably get one for like 70 80
grand really
yes that is the red one oh that's what
you
bro you look young as hell i know so
that was your first card to the prius
yeah and that was you buying it right
there that's me buying it yeah that's me
after the center
oh bruh we got to get you that picture
we got to get it we got to get
now look this picture
please bro we gotta get you out of that
syndrome how are you
how are you right there brittany uh i
don't know that's probably six years ago
okay so what you thirty nine months so i
was 31 yeah
early 30s damn bro and what's
what shirt is that that is that's the
levi's shirt okay i'm about to say all
right but then
my family's always wanted a porsche so i
was the first one to get a portion i set
that picture my damn like look what i
just got
damn he replied back oh that's cool my
friend has a gt2
what's that mean that's the car i have
now it's like the ultimate portion oh so
that's the ultimate porsche the well
there's
there you go there's the 918 spider
which nobody has
nobody has it nobody has it's like a
million dollar car oh god i don't
danny ricardo the driver has one uh-huh
the car you have right now is really
expensive
uh i mean yeah yeah damn yeah that's a
19.
you you're never going to see them it's
an ultimate super car
they race with those right uh not that
one i can't get down with smaller cars
that's not a small car i don't like a
bugatti
like built it with a porsche body do you
like those you're [ __ ]
yeah i would give my left leg for that
car
or that one yes well let's not talk
about legs you know
yeah and you're like listen you could
give me the fat legs like that girl has
for that car for that car yes how you
doing push down or you only have a
horror pedal i don't give a [ __ ]
1.7 mill one point 1.7 mil
that's the starting rate correct and
that and that's also like
what makes it worth them what you got to
tell me about it it's gonna understand
it's super it's super rare
the engine yeah like it's never like
it's like they don't make a lot of them
no [ __ ] no no i think floyd got one
stupid that i don't know drake has one
you got to be a real now you got to be a
real car like
lebron got uh people videoing me oh yeah
he's in that wait wait wait wait lebron
he's a 19 spider
so the only people like i think jerry
seinfeld has one
uh lebron has one danny ricardo has one
but you have to be a car guy to have a
car you gotta be a big car guy like
oh mayweather's not a car guy he's not
he likes
he gets bugattis because they're a
[ __ ] million dollars
what's some other good fast cars i don't
know cars like you got that black one
damn see but see it's not a small car
that's what he's
doing big yeah yeah that's a big you
don't feel you don't feel all tight in
your porsche no not at all
you know no that's why porsche is the
best because big dudes can drive them
well i mean but when i can't we're both
in there like i can't figure it was
tough
okay we were both in there but i'm
almost by myself
[ __ ] his ass is in my face right now
and that car crash was hanging down
because his pants was sagging
they pick him up yeah he gets an ass
first he's all naked
shawn must be cold out there
oh yeah frank the tank frank joe must be
cold out there huh frank
what's he say he's like you think
chick-fil-a's oh yeah or kfc
gosh he's a goat will ferrell i love
will ferrell
yeah he's so [ __ ] i was watching this
don't own funny or die
are they still doing that oh yeah yeah
they still do yeah their office is right
up on uh santa monica
that's huge yeah so so funny dude i
watched uh
what's that one uh with him and mark
wahlberg the other guys
[Applause]
uh stevia guitar for christmas
not just the guitar so how i know cars
is how you guys know
oh my god is that a good guitar it's
like i had no idea what type of guitar
is i just saw him looking at it and i
made a mess
online oh yeah and then i saw and then i
you know i helped stevie i was like yo
you should get steve's this guitar yeah
like five minutes after he was looking
at it so i was like i wonder if stevie
texted chappelle to tell me
oh oh really it was like a team effort a
little team
so it's a dope guitar apparently i
didn't really know much about it i think
chappelle knows more about it
uh it's tom morello's signature one is a
fender one
and so it's a fender tom morello and tom
morello's from uh rage against the
machine good
hey there we go i'm a rage fan there you
go okay
damn what does that mean
that's her logo oh
oh he was sending me pictures he was so
excited it was like
it says soul power on it yeah well the
night sticker decal that you that's like
on earth that's something like oh 12
grand yeah
well no goddamn cat
but uh yeah he never really celebrated
christmas so i was like okay i'll do
something and you went you went to
uh i went to sam ashley yeah that's
really really cool
i didn't realize i thought it was like a
regular guitar no that's apparently it's
not
good for you damn that's cool yeah
yeah was stevie crunk about it yeah he
was crack about the guy who sold me the
guitar was crunk about i had no idea
what i was buying
it's a big it's like a big yeah is that
standard price for guitar
no how much is the guitar regularly yeah
i mean it all depends
it literally all depends you can i mean
is 1200 on the high end or no
that's i was i'm not seeing this
collector like the american guitars are
worth a lot more
really yeah like if they're
american-made they're worth a lot oh
damn
why is it uh more expensive if it's
american-made i don't
you know what i don't know that's the
best [ __ ] yeah
it's just yeah and then uh the science
cards the uh like i would say would you
say like lower that the mexican ones
i don't know what the damn x is my
guitars yeah they yeah
really good i had a mexican telly
mariachi man
do you wish your girl got you a do you
wish your girl got you a guitar
no i got i got three right now i'm good
right now
it's a good flex because like i mean
when i have bigger space you know what i
mean because i got some guitars
oh i plan on having like having a
full-on music room
yeah the collector's items it's
that one's japanese yeah and i bought
that when i was a kid for like 1200 i
saved all my money
yeah yeah you have good good guitars now
tin
he has great guitars they're not like
crazy but they're they're good
that's the only electric you have i have
a ibanez bass too
the one that's one that's really
expensive is the that gibson es
355 i want to say what's the guitar that
you can play with a cup
like they like to learn with the string
oh it's just it's just the thing
no that's just the uh plastic acrylic
glasses yeah
new teacher i told how about i told
stevie i'm like hey teach me to play the
guitar on the road he's like
i can't even teach a man yeah like he
just came to three i think
he said he likes three things so he
doesn't know how to teach something
that's what he said
he's like i can't teach you i think the
one uh that red one
that's the one uh noel gallagher i think
noah got a little guy
i know right
hey someone wants to teach you uh he's
some guy from one direction
he was like in the i don't know if he
was like uh what's his name from one
direction
guitar let me his name harry styles
wants to teach you because i love him
brendan uh okay no so i guess he did
guitar for
one direction or something like that
like you made him a guitar or sandy
beals
he's in england i think and he wants to
teach you guitar via zoom
yeah something like that oh he said that
yeah he messaged me about that i'd love
that oh that's dope brendan can i zoom
in with you dude
you get you you know what you got to
learn you got to learn a song you got to
come in you got to jam with it i do
i know he played bass for one direction
yeah he's the real deal yeah that's a
basically yeah yeah i want to uh
yeah it's on my bucket list yeah come on
now yeah it'd be fun
i know it is weird like i get what
stevie's saying when he says like i
couldn't [ __ ] teach you
really yeah but if you know how to play
it should be pretty [ __ ] easy but
it's like
any skill i have i could because me and
chin are going back and forth i can be
like chin just
throw me a g and then i'll i'll follow
along with him like that
yeah but if i'm like hey what's the g
chord you could be like bing bing bing
you could teach him teach him right now
you can teach right now yeah the g is
the easiest it's like this
it's like flipping something it really
yeah but and then and then you just got
to put it together
it's like i was good in high school it's
gonna be weird because i don't know
i was good with my finger like this i
wish it was acoustic
uh do you know you don't have your
martin uh i just i freaking i need to
get that at home yeah
you can unplug it i can roll it out you
want me to i got you
we're all set on your rapping okay
how did your uh sound clap did you get
the soundcloud yeah yeah i put it on
it was just so funny there's two ways
you can play
i mean to get the fuller sound i mean
okay it's going to be this is
weird it's a it's out of tune but you're
going to put your middle finger
on the uh low e the top chord top the
top string the chords go
e f g no no
no g f h so that's our chords those are
these strings
my bad i'm [ __ ] trying to learn here
man that's a mess
this is the right environment
chord third all right third fret okay
and then you'll
take your index finger you'll do it on
uh a
okay sec second string uh
[ __ ] it's gonna be on the second fret
all right then you're gonna take your
ring finger
and put it down here on the high e
that's a lot third okay
right so like it's a lot if you look at
it it looks like i'm flipping you off
yeah yeah you're like this yeah and then
you just
that sounds nice mm-hmm what if you what
if he left right
what if he left-handed yeah it wouldn't
be left-handed he's got to do the string
the other way around
yeah i mean i know people that are
left-handed that play that way
okay hold on let me place your finger
no no no no no no no it's gone all right
so
yeah your index finger people to the
people on audio
we have brendan with a guitar in his
hand bring your finger
oh chappelle teaching him like this now
i look like he's flipping us off
but he's not so he's playing the string
let's let's do g
dude that's pretty damn good that's
pretty damn good that's the g
i like he's hooked knocked out
there it is all right so hey uh what's
his name sandy beals
sandy beals yeah sandy beals hey you got
your first zoom yeah yeah
dude that's awesome yeah you should do
it i would take advantage of him up on
it yeah yeah
can i have the login information no alex
all tuning in as well
but how did your uh soundcloud i got a
lot i got a hundred and
uh 43 plays and 85 comments
ooh that's good and how are the comments
they're great they love them
everything's positive yeah everything's
positive that's good i'm i'm thinking
about
like going on tour with this rolly boy
oh i don't think so
okay so well album is in the works
you're doing a whole album i don't know
listen you doubted me on the first song
y'all doubted me right
and it surprised y'all no i didn't
what's surprising okay the next didn't
know how good
i'm dissing the next one is that a doubt
does that mean i'm doubting it when i
say i don't know
yeah i mean we all did let's be honest
he's rapping
all right i'm sorry my next disc i post
i posted the clip and said just what
everybody wants another soundcloud
i saw that i saw that well listen a lot
of people was like bro you should come
out with an album i was like all right
who
who should i diss next a lot of people
said logic so i'm uh dude music music
label
you don't even need a record label
anymore you really don't you could do
everything independent
yeah they're so [ __ ] crazy yeah
seriously like even playboy carter he
had people
going back to his situation he had this
weight for two years and he released
that trash out
two years two years yeah but he released
another crazy contract no just released
it whenever he wanted to
like and he's just really disciplined if
you're independent
yeah yeah well you also got to love
music like we love larry jones
and uh larry jones we just play this
album in the car he released whenever he
wants to release
that's cool he's independent so oh so
you so so a label has to tell you when
to drop it out what they need there's a
whole marketing plan they tell you when
everything you signed a 360 deal they
like kind of
you're on if charles manson just had
this no no no
dude he'd be fine if charles manson got
a record deal nobody would have got
nobody got murdered and if independent
was a thing back then he could have done
it
he could have [ __ ] done it all he had
to do was beach boys want to [ __ ] them
yeah
stole his music dude he stole his music
stole his music
how many songs do they have that are his
uh there's a few that are inspired by
him but then there's
one that's straight up his lyrics his
song everything
and they need to hear his music all
right oh [ __ ] it's
his music's on itunes but he can play on
youtube too
charles manson i gotta hear it okay
are we about to do this and you know
in uh i hate that picture i know but
that's then why they do them like that
on the picture though
listen up bros 2020 sucked it's a new
year
so get in with the new year with your
new balls
i'm talking about our sponsor manscape
manscape is the best
in men's below the belt grooming all
right
they have the perfect tools for your
jewels they're helping over 2
million men all over the world get rid
of that
hair all over your body if you let
yourself go in 2020 while in quarantine
you're super hairy let manscape help you
right now they're here for you guys
reboot 2021 all right reboot it baby
uh manscape is here to give you a fresh
start in 2021 with their perfect package
3.0 that has all the right tools for the
job all right
come out of this quarantine with clean
balls thanks to lawnmower 3.0 this
waterproof skinscape trimmer
will reduce snakes to your two best
friends talking about your nutsacks all
right
all right it's also time to freshen up
down there this new year with the crop
preserver
anti-chafing ball deodorant and
moisturizer i put on my thighs when i
ride my bike
uh 2020 was awful so make sure your boys
are refreshed and ready to go
for new beginnings in 2021 bring in the
right way manscape even threw in their
shed travel bag
to keep all your goodies stored all
right speaking of comfort the manscape
anti-chafing boxer briefs are also
included
and are hands down the best underwear
you will ever wear
uh a guy with hairy balls is like 20 20.
don't be that guy
get 20 off and free shipping with the
code fighter 20
at manscape.com your balls will thank
you again get 20
off and free shipping with code fighter
20 at manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
youth code fighter 20
happy new year to your balls and you
know in uh
i hate that picture i know but that's
then why they do them like that on the
picture though
that i and you know in uh you saw once
upon a time in hollywood
i haven't seen it yet i need to watch it
you love it white michael that's my
favorite
white mike says i have to watch it
right oh he's good
i got a lot for a killer he killing it
he didn't kill him
never killed anybody okay that we know
of mm-hmm
crazy though right if they were full of
goddamn
he's got a full album yeah so if you
guys want to check it out
and then also uh in once upon a time
hollywood when they pick up the
manson girls the family they're actually
singing one of his real songs
really yeah they used to do it all the
time did um
his music's on itunes yeah i didn't
check it oh yeah
but i i wonder if he was getting money
for that well he's dead now
no no like like well i'm just trying to
see how long it's been on itunes
you know like if he was alive no but be
also you can't make money off stuff
uh when you're in prison really man so
they just like if you wrote about i mean
my dad was making money in prison
different
but if like if your dad wrote a book on
his crimes and then tried selling the
book you can't make money off that why
are you a prophet
isn't there a law against uh people who
have been convicted of a crime
benefiting from
crime like o.j simpson can't make money
off when he was in jail he couldn't make
he couldn't no
but you can't profit off of the crime
that you committed but like
but like i thought he has that thing
with the nfl where he gets money oj does
he
that's different though but that's just
football yes football but they're not
paying them because he murdered crime
yeah they're paying him because you rush
for 2000 yards for the buffalo bills
i know but like while he was in prison
he was still getting that
so that money he was getting he's
getting but also that money also i think
was just collected they're garnishing
his wages because he owed child support
other [ __ ] mm-hmm so they didn't ever
they have a like a set reason on how
they can like
get that money back child support so
with that retirement fund like
uh he gets money monthly monthly how
much
and then it depends how how many years
you played and how many games you played
in
you have to get like i think it's four
seasons and three gets weird
like four games four four seasons like
three games
to get a certain minimum every year got
it like i remember my boy
did they still do that oh yeah oh yeah
really oh yeah big time
damn yeah like jerry rice makes banks
you know how long he played
this nba does nba do that everyone does
also hall of fame you get a lot of money
as well if you're getting introducted to
yeah
you're certain do you really that's why
you're certain stipend yeah you want to
be in the hall of fame
but like my boy klopp he was like he
played for four years
in like certain amount of games he's
like man here playing one more game then
i get stipend every year
wow did he did he did it
wow and then you get paid off if you
were a starter how many balls you got
like
there's all sorts of yeah yeah yeah i'm
gonna pay for the rest of your life i
remember it and that's how it should be
because you dedicate your life to that
sport
yeah for an entire life yeah and then
you can't play anymore
the [ __ ] up you can't play anymore
because your body whatever fails on you
but you dedicated your entire life to
that sport
yeah you should be compensated
afterwards yeah there's no other
profession
you know there's nothing i get nothing
for cheerleading no offense oh any
on any given sunday uh llc made a quote
like man
if he's not he's audible in the plays i
need the runs to get my bonus if i don't
get my bonus
i don't get my money and what do you
mean by that like yo so
if you score it so like in like let's
take uh derrick henry
okay killing it might win mvp yeah i
mean back-to-back seasons 15 years aaron
rodgers is killing it i know but
i mean what they have 16 almost 1700
yards he's in more games
so he might be in the conversation but
so in his contract it's like if he
scores this many touchdowns he'll make
this much more money
yeah if if he uh carries the ball this
many times and make this much more money
there's all those bonuses and then
everybody gets
i think if you get to the playoffs
everybody gets like fifty thousand
dollars a game
a game if but then if you get to the uh
championship game you get a hundred
thousand dollars you get the super ball
everybody gets two hundred thousand
dollars
like there's oh if you win the super
bowl you get oh everybody gets bonuses
everyone
everyone knows everyone that's why all
these players want to make it
and make me want to play harder yeah
speaking of that that's pretty [ __ ]
dope yeah that's cool
any good i respect that my name is willy
football movie screaming yeah yeah that
movie that's the
latest you think that's the best
football movie oh by far yeah
for a professional mm-hmm best college
football yeah
uh no i think he was nominated i don't
as the coach yeah i don't think so you
don't think so
pretty much the movie is great bro
that's speech at the end
come on ray that was a good alright
that's a good idea
and i can't do it for you you've never
heard that motivational speech by al
pacino
yeah that's it wait what
yeah yeah they used to like at your
practice or whatever yeah
no yeah he didn't know carmen i'm pretty
sure that a lot of bring up that
inspirational speech it's fantastic i
apologize for the listeners
i thought i thought so you know uh jamie
foxx and how cool j got in a real fight
a real fight i heard
why i don't know two talented guys yeah
i play this
i'm about to cry we listen before
football games too
second tier of the episode i don't know
what to say really dennis quaid
yeah come on man he's just token white
quarterback
look at jim brown in the back his team
chillin
bill bellamy that's gonna make the
[ __ ] difference
between winning and losing
now i can't make it that two-face yeah
yeah that's him
you can stop it just stop it bro i'm
getting yo first of all
come on you know dennis quay's wife is
in her 20s he like 60 something
yeah yeah and all right shout out to him
um jim how do you feel about that
huh how do you feel about that i thought
i was i was just like oh
[ __ ] all right our 27 year olds not
attractive
i mean they're not saying attracted to a
66 year old man well
hey i don't know the relationship plenty
of housewives marry older guys
true she's true
he's had a lot of work done he has yeah
especially now
he's got a lot of work done dude she's
39 by the way oh says 39 years
difference
oh 27. okay
she's 27. i mean she doesn't look like
she's 27. no no
yeah let me pee real quick okay oh so we
had current events now
hurry i don't know all right yeah you
just said you had to pee
i had to pee so bad we up early we
it's 10 30 like i was like oh it feels
like work it's almost noon
but yeah but i don't know i'm saying
well we started our call time yeah
we need to hear about eight but we
didn't have below the belt today
why why no fights ah there's no fights
for like two more weeks so we
did the best of this week and brandon
want to give the time off to the
employees too that's what's going to be
doing every week
hell yeah curvats sure all right
okay this is a very sad one on christmas
day
there was a bombing at uh over in
nashville the downtown area
oh he's actually not that sad though
nobody died except for his dumbass
well i think it's unfortunate that there
was a bombing on christmas day
thankfully nobody died except for him
but
yeah the bomber was identified do you
care if we say the name or like show his
face i know some places
don't like doing that really yeah some
places don't like doing people
publicity yeah publicity no show this
dummy listen
this is a guy this is a guy that decided
to
load up an rv full of bombs he made an
announcement telling everybody clear the
area
he blew up the att building uh because
uh he got really deep into 5g
because he thought 5g was like they
think they'd be able to like watch
america and stuff like that
so he went people got to stay offline
you went too deep in conspiracy theories
and also i mean you died dude you blew
up
uh you didn't blow up the att building
you did some damage and some of the
wi-fi in the area was
down for a hot second but did you really
think you're going to shut down
5g by doing this it's just a so far
but thank god nobody was around yeah he
did it i believe it started at like
five or six in the morning is when the
explosion went off yeah there was
a there was audio during that time
playing
and nearby residents can hear of saying
like get out of the area there's a bomb
evacuate now like it was him it was yeah
it was him microphone out of his rv
saying get out of the area yeah the
bombs gonna go off get out of the area
because he didn't want to kill people
yeah he just wanted to kill himself and
blow up the building
and shut stop the 5g you know how insane
you have to be
oh so he wanted to kill him so he went
trying to get out of there no he was a
suicide bombing
yeah 5 30.
8 30 in the morning because it couldn't
be worse if he wanted to inflict pain on
people he would have died
wow yeah it could have been really bad
so yeah that's unfortunate but that's
all we know about that
at least just he died i want to
piggyback off cat's crown event real
quick so
you know sam sam tripoli is a very very
conspiracy
oriented guy he sent me this
and i don't know who this person is but
it says mg show so apparently this
this is the source of the explosion and
the rvs over here i don't know how good
this is
how much this says but watch
huh but i mean who knows what if this
video is edited or whatever
they're saying the rv didn't actually
explode the rv the bombs were in the rv
they're saying the bombs were over there
and then i saw this this morning but
then why was he
why why did the rv blow up i don't know
right los angeles
they've tied a suspect whoa what's this
i guess he signed over two homes to this
los angeles executive and that she can't
talk about it because it's a federal
investigation
gave her 100 home not in l.a right i
don't know
nashville i believe it was in antioch
nashville
another house where so he left her some
so what is sam basically saying
there's some sort of conspiracy towards
this like maybe he's like the guy that
they're blaming but there could be a
bigger thing that's happening i don't
know
bro they turn nevermind everything
everything
meanwhile everybody in the hood knew you
know why because it's that's more
interesting than the actual truth
truth is this crazy dumbass is a
conspiracy
guy got really into 5g decided to blow
up
[ __ ] 18t yeah that's it end of story
so he believed in conspiracies correct
oh big time but is it like
i mean is it like like are they
like like some conspiracies are
warranted right
like uh yeah like jfk clearly conspiracy
uh god 911 is tricky dude
but but we'll say we'll say is like the
most majority people believe in that
conspiracy
oh no i don't i don't think so do you
think majority people think it was the
inside job
oh yeah no that's all i ever hear people
say it's a whole documentary michael
moore
you're literally the first person i've
ever heard say that you don't think it's
an inside job no
no no no no no no i'd love to hear your
perspective
all i ever hear is the other because
perspective's not fun it's not it's not
exciting that al qaeda terrorists took
over planes of ram into the building
that's not fun yeah or there has to be
something more to it
now there there's definitely more to it
where those guys were educated in
florida
the the way they took over the plane now
did the government know it was gonna
happen i don't i don't know that stuff
but do i think our government blew up
tower
seven or whether no i don't i don't
think our government blew that [ __ ] up
did did they know about it i don't know
but the the conspiracies happen because
that's funner than the truth
mm-hmm damn all right
there's a lot but i don't think the
majority of america thinks it was inside
job
oh i don't know i don't think i don't
think majority of america
would join the people because i think
documentary doesn't mean [ __ ]
because if americans thought it was
inside job and 3
000 people were murdered by getting
blown up on
the [ __ ] uh twin towers there would
be
[ __ ] riot gazoo it would be
insane if that if that came out i think
i think it's just the people you're
probably surrounded with what are you
talking about
that's majority of the people i the
people i talk to
listen we all go to documentaries we
watch we watch documentaries
but what's that what's the point of a
documentary to
treat
narrative okay but that's why he didn't
believe the michael jackson one no yeah
but but i'm saying that was just a shame
michael jackson but if a documentary
comes out don't you think like
you think all those are facts no i'm
just saying i'm just going
off the the fact that like majority
people believe in this let's
do a documentary no no no [ __ ] no i
don't think so
if it was that's not why you create a
documentary no i'm saying okay
why do people because like making a
murder right yes huge documentary
yes huge yes if you talk to anyone from
that local government are you talking
from that town like oh dude it's clear
as day he murdered
those people but the documentary makes
it seem like it's all up in the air
like oh maybe he didn't do it like no
it's clear it's dead he's in prison for
a reason
okay but the documentary what do you
think of who you think behind the 9 11
attack look wait u.s government
what the u.s government is they're
asking different
countries how many people think that it
was done by u.s government the red ones
so
indonesia is 14 china's nine percent no
not very small percentage let's go to
usa
i don't see us here for some reason
which is crazy i don't i'm not in china
i wouldn't say the majority americans
think
uh i could be wrong all right
well that's saddam hussein no i think
there's a lot of people who think it's
inside jobs i don't
yeah i don't like baseball as a
documentary no i don't think anybody's
majority
but but i but i you can't say a majority
off of a documentary okay you're right
that's right
but but there is like it's weird to me
like the way the tower fell
super suspect yeah like there's somebody
michael moore do you believe in michael
moore
do you believe like no i don't what do
you do i mean he's a doc
he makes documentaries okay he's super
like you know anti-trump like
you know he's a documentary guy so he's
gonna make you the most entertaining
possible yeah i got you
okay but i'm sure i'm sure there's some
like a lot of stuff i'm sure there's
some truth to it you know i don't know
but do i think our government and the
president was
in on it no but there's
some stuff that's the way the tower fell
a lot of it was weird
and i know they did get warnings
previously that like hey this was going
to happen
and then also when that stuff happens
and you know and then we went to war you
know
in the middle east like again we make a
ton of money off war
like we make a [ __ ] ton of money there's
a lot of stuff going on there
but again the conspiracy is so much more
funner than the truth
yeah true and that's and this guy got
caught up like flat earth is insane
you ever seen the flat earther where the
guy's like dude all you got to do
he's trying to prove that the earth is
flat he's like if the earth isn't flat
the sun will do this and he's like
holding this little device
but it shows the sun like rising he's
like [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's so funny he's like super flattered
and he's like oh really if it's if it
the earth is flat then
you won't see any uh curve and the sun
won't come up like this and he has this
whole device he's like waiting for hours
and you just see the sun come up he's on
damn i can't shut the video up he's like
that shit's still flat hashtag
now the one that's interesting that
nobody can prove is are we in a
simulation
that one's interesting i was talking to
eric weinstein and he was he believes he
has the math to like prove
like he's coming up with the math to
prove like yo we really believe that
we are all in assimilation like all this
so you remember do you watch men in
black
i know i know i actually which one one
or two the second one you remember at
the end when he
opened the locker and he saw like yo
what what is this it's a whole new world
yeah it's like yo
is that assimilation eric believes that
like we're all in assimilation
and i talked to brian about this as well
like they really believe and he's coming
up with the math to prove it
like i don't get too deep into that
because i was like this hurt my brain
yeah but these well the problem is if
you think we're in a simulation it's
like what's the point of living you know
what i'm saying
when you hear stuff like that i'm like
well you already know not just luke but
that but that eric weinstein is also a
numbers guy
like he's very like black and white
numbers analytics right
yeah yes he's gonna be super biased over
there
got you right and to have to say he has
a formula to prove that we're in a
simulation
i'm sure he's a great guy he's a great
he's he's a man
like what he's a mathematician the
seventh most smartest guy in the world
really yeah they voted i voted as well i
don't know
it went through so he's just he's the
what he's a for one he's a mathematician
but
it's a it's a i was talking to him
another day what's his job title i know
he's it's a uh
unified theory of physics uh yes
physically so he thinks we're in a
simulation
a lot of people think about it really
how does that come how did these people
come up with this [ __ ]
well bro they they study this all their
lives they come up with these like
genius
and what does this mean simulation like
bro it's like simulation means like
you know the games you know the game you
turn up like oh sims
like sims sure yeah yeah okay but you're
not
like there's someone controlling it
almost like uh
i wouldn't say control i'd be like yo
yeah let's just type so you're not you
i'm
me but it's like it's a simulation it's
all like none of it nothing's real good
i don't believe in it at all bro that is
so it's
awesome it's depressing as [ __ ] and also
it's like i yeah he has one kid
if you have kids it'd be hard to see why
white mike was trying to tell me this
and i i was
not really getting it because it's just
because i'm like man now i believe in
aliens i believe in that there's
there's life like i think the universe
is so
space is so big and we're so minut that
there's
there's another malek on another planet
a double gengar yeah
yeah but i'll talk to him and get more
of a clear
we're good okay but yeah yeah this i
don't know that that would exhaust my
brain
i don't know i just no i i just i don't
know i just want to live but it's
interesting
you're going to live it's interesting
yeah i want like
i'm not [ __ ] on it but and if you're
into it and that's your thing dude but
i'm like what does this do for me
nothing if anything it shouldn't be like
oh in a simulation what's the point of
living
yeah so yeah i i mean
yeah like did you see did you see i
don't know if this camera would be super
depressing that girl who committed
suicide jumped off that fancy bill in
new york
and then that she set it up so she
posted
a suicide note on instagram the next day
she scheduled the message
she was like there's literally nothing
anybody could do that's how i want to go
out
like i want to thank my mom parents
everybody stopping by like you meant a
lot to me but
this is and she's like if you're reading
this uh and you don't know
boy you're in for a shock sit down and
she's like hopefully i'm i'm gone
and hopefully i'm not you know just
[ __ ] up in the hospital because then
this is so
it was incredibly depressing because she
was being nice she was i didn't think
she ever i didn't find it depressing i
found it
like that's her choice she said she has
that free will that's her [ __ ] choice
to kill herself whose choice is it yeah
but
she didn't have kids or nothing that's
her thing but the people
when you commit suicide there couldn't
be a more selfish act because
you don't suffer i don't know what you
go on to yeah everybody around you
suffers you
you [ __ ] up the entire network of your
family the entire
being of your family so you don't have
to deal with it yeah because you're out
it's so [ __ ] up but i mean i mean
imagine
going through that much pain and
suffering to where you have to
you know you want to do yourself i
understand both
sides there's two my best friend he he
uh committed suicide but he was he was
going through
uh withdrawals from uh heroin and like
he wasn't
it just wasn't him you know it wasn't he
wasn't in his right
state of mind yeah like i mean knowing
the dude that he
was into what he you know what he became
based off of like the heroine
it just you know and i it's just crazy
it's [ __ ] maybe if they could how
long ago is this
he um because there's stuff that was 09.
they can give heroin addicts right
there's a certain substance so his thing
was kind of a mess-up situation he was
in
jail he was serving like a 19-day
sentence or something like that that's
not bad
and well when you go in you have to tell
them you're heroin at it yeah they're
supposed to take care of you
but he always said they didn't yeah you
know what i mean so i think he was just
going crazy
yeah and then commit suicide yeah where
if you could if someone could have got
to him or gave him something to get by
yeah he probably would have continued on
yeah that's different this girl seems
like she was like
who knows what state of mind she's in
but clear minded
wrote that whole thing you know and was
like this is this is my choice
i want to do it's like that dr
kravorkian do you remember him
yeah he was helping people who didn't
want to be everywhere pass away
yeah and like he went to prison for it
which is insane to me
yeah because it was their choice yes i
think it's just the consequences of
you your loved ones have to deal with
that we have to face the backlash what
you
like we miss you yeah you know yes i get
with you what i just said
yep that was the point i made yeah let's
move on
no but it's true though it's like you
don't have to deal with it you're just
out
then everybody else has to deal with
yeah that's a tough one
yeah i mean yeah that's what i'm saying
i get both sides yeah he has a
you know his son is oh he had kids yeah
yeah
that's a different man yeah you have
kids you dude yeah you [ __ ] up check
out because you're gonna [ __ ] up those
those little dudes life they grow up
without your dad you know they're dead
committed suicide like there's so much
it's it's it's i mean it's very very
tough and you know
he he's his son is super blessed to have
you know
really great people in his life me being
one of them you know i
do everything i can to like you know
because i was the closest thing to his
dad
you know what i mean so like it does you
know help him a lot but it is tough it's
not this
it's not the same you know what i mean
it's not the same you know
you know he's very appreciative of me of
having me of me being in his life for
sure
he'll write me father's day cards and
stuff like that so like sweet you know
but
i mean send him gifts and [ __ ] all the
time yeah you know
of course yeah
[Laughter]
yeah he's got really really great people
in his life i mean but it is a tough
situation but then again back to
something
to come full circle if you believe in
simulation it's not really a big deal is
it
because someone you already hear yeah
simulation because what
like your assimilation again is like
controlled what was the definition again
so we can um right here is this the
pythagorean theorem
no that's a mark you knew what i was
talking about huh
don't look at the asian person
so it's a computer simulation that's
overseen by some higher form of
intelligence yeah oh so they think
aliens are controlling this
no you don't have to be an alien like a
higher some higher intelligence like
spiritually the the queen
full circle i know this is off topic but
i found out that
uh so the feds you know the feds was
like how they
like came about through families like so
let's say
um so it stands for family every day no
so families run usa
not the feds the families okay that's
all right
you can hang out with sam i know right
yeah where you've been yeah
now there's powerful most powerful
families yeah so i'm saying that
dictate a lot of the media they own the
media corporation
and politicians yes okay okay all right
i wanted to tell you the
rothschilds the rock childs and um it
was jesuits
uh the getty would you get it
who was the president that met with the
four families that's how they started to
face do you know the
the president's name how long ago it was
a supreme court this is like you know
years ago hold on you're you you're
you're you've gotten deep down and uh
that's why i was quiet
i will say this a lot of that conspiracy
stuff
a lot a lot of the followers are
uneducated like they don't have a
background in history or anything like
that
cool so conspiracy is just easier to
look up and get into
because if you really want to get into
the history of like the united states or
europe or
africa or china or russia like it's
you got to go deep so much easier to
watch a video
yeah on a conspiracy and just get up
these little oh my gosh
it drives me crazy like the non-keto
epilido
he'll call me he'll he'll be dropping
some one time and i'll i'll be like hey
dude
i don't want to have this conversation
i'm like you can have that world
yeah to you but like it's like if i'm on
the phone with you i don't [ __ ] care
again some conspiracies i believe in
some are just yeah insane
yeah just like anything though yeah i
was just doing research this weekend
don't worry about like jack o island
you know yeah here he goes well no
jekyll you heard of jekyll
island uh not like episode
you got into the conspiracy stuff no not
this are you into that
no i just want to expand my mind but at
the same time i get what you're saying
like
of course somebody expand your mind to
some real [ __ ] well no this is this is
actual history is pretty dope this is
weird this is real like this is not fake
it's not a conspiracy theory this is
like the creation of the fest did you
know how it came about like how
like there's a lot to think about bro
well you talking about jackal island
it's not it's it's
all right anyways we can get off of it
my bad but there's a youtube channel i
guess if you want to watch it yeah you
can watch it you'll worry about it yeah
that's the creation of the feds and i
didn't know the so these families run
the country i'm you think the feds run
the country but these families
running like you said families have huge
influence well they own a lot all the
media outlets
big corporations you know oil businesses
the the stock exchange the stocks
exactly exactly i'm saying
all right yeah there's i mean there's
that you know what
what can you do with that information
what do you mean just know it
you know how the americas ran and stuff
like that bro you want to know what
you're living in do you live in america
are you a citizen [ __ ] it get the
background of it get the origin story
okay but you could you could get the
background but there's there's some
legitimate background too like there's
certain books you can read i'm not i'm
not
i'm not i'm not knocking what you what
you say i guess just yeah you are uh
okay maybe i am but maybe i was getting
a little aggressive and i apologize no
problem
i'll let miss barry know that i did good
today also um
millionaire next door and also it
teaches you like the
the gist of how everything comes about
but anyways what were you saying i'm
just saying like
i mean but like even the movie industry
like the way
like american sniper like a lot of
especially back in like the 40s
you know the music the film industry in
the military
like the the military owned a lot of it
so the propaganda they put out
you know what i'm saying like it still
goes on today mm-hmm
that's true i guess yeah i mean i don't
know but it's no difference with these
documentaries like they have
it's probably like a lot of people yeah
yeah and that's
like there's a narrative tell all these
documentaries because it has to be
entertaining
it has to be you you want to move the
needle yeah 100
and it goes back to that guy killing the
atnt building so
conspiracy theories 5g
what else you got so in other news
a bunch of fans have been submitting
this we did talk about this after we
filmed
last wednesday they want you to react to
this
um big sean has officially been hired as
the creative director of
innovation for the detroit what's that
mean like with jersey
so yeah he's gonna be he's gonna have a
huge hand in how
the merch is gonna look like in uh
stadium performances your whole sort of
like experience when you go to a pistons
game is going to be based off of
big sean's new let's go is that what
drake does for the raptors yes
yes but yeah he owns he owns part of the
raptors oh he does yeah yeah oh i didn't
know that yeah also detroit hey
enjoy oh 72. how's your opener against
the cavs you
lost game winner oh and 72 but okay
are you talking [ __ ] to all of detroit
right now detroit pistons until he gets
out the office
you know you have a winning season and
let this guy go let him let him fly
okay you know he's doing his thing
he's letting you do your thing yeah
brother he let you he let you come out
that looks similar i don't know you guys
do look soon
bro yeah just know the rap game belongs
to rolly boy
all right
you start making money off of it you
just say [ __ ]
you know about your money
in the g yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah return
the favor
exactly life is all broke for life man
what else you got what up though
okay so michael jackson's neverland
ranch sold
22 million dollars they wanted a hundred
million originally when it went on sale
the state was asking for a hundred
million uh after a few months when they
couldn't sell they went down to i
believe 62 million
but they ended up selling for 22 million
they finally sold that damn
that place is dope though great area
great location santa
santa barbara yeah you could i think you
could see like off the freeway that's
pretty dope
you been i've seen it oh you've seen it
yeah i've driven by it
the guy who bought it so crazy
billionaire who owns part of soho house
here
and he wanted originally to create some
sort of like country club but he
realized that
that probably wouldn't be the best place
for a country club but
he won the estate as an investment wow
i think you'd make it dope you could
make it it's [ __ ] huge
i mean i'd knock it down and just
rebuild on it especially if i was a
billionaire
damn you do you get that get that
[ __ ] theme park back popping get the
[ __ ]
train going yeah giraffes
walking by the trees that michael would
climb on he likes to climb trees i don't
know if you want to make a theme park
there and
have fun kids yeah that is true yeah
that's true
you make it cool though yeah you can
definitely make it cool what else you
got
i just got some instagram posts
instagram posts
that's cool this is the first one i
don't know
this is some asian [ __ ] yeah this is
really
so it's a it's a human crane machine
thing that's kind of hard
that goes hard bro he's popping a bunch
of [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying what's in there
these candy i think they're all candies
yeah looks like you get all that
put me in there that's a velcro
i know rice put me in there velcro just
have it all the time
bro that's so tough so bro give me they
actually saw them
if they don't have that in america yet
come on man
they do that shoes they have for shoes
that you can say oh they actually sell
them too it's found
on alibaba of course alibaba like two
grand
so i have a boy who does those shoe
things that's a comic in canada yeah he
invested in one
and they're all you know they're all
it's all hype like it's all fake
so they they control they can say like
out of one out of 500 players gonna win
like it's
they control it yeah oh so you know how
many times
it's okay you know i'm talking about
that shoe joint right yeah
and all the shoe stores where you can
get like yeezys exactly that right there
really it's all fake i was about to say
yeah
but they don't have your size it's just
a box it's just a box there's like one
out of like a thousand
but he controls it back yeah that's so
messed up dude
you know the ones that you see at like a
restaurant or whatever like out of norms
you'll see like the little crane games
for stuffed animals i actually had a
friend that was so good at it he would
get it almost every single time
real technique to it yeah there's a
technique because i could never it's
always like you know as soon as i grab
it and it moved it would drop it yeah
yeah but he got it almost every single
time we were like what the [ __ ] i wonder
what his technique is i don't know
just a feel for it you can't do he just
has a ton of [ __ ] stuffed
animals he would always give it to girls
though yeah
hey a little player a little player
that's that's hard oh
that's nice at home uh i just saw this
oh this is an rv
arby's menu item that i guess exists but
it's like a secret menu item
it's all the meats into one sandwich
never the heartbeats goes hard
i can't do it people sleep on arby's
they're curly fries
we talked about this last time my mouth
is right
mouth is watering look at the curly
fries in the back
yeah you see him you see him look at
that back
sandwich with the cheese on top oh you
better stop they got the meat
now let's try to how about malik trying
to offer us chick-fil-a earlier
to be on the outside looking in i'm
proud of y'all
thank you thanks because i didn't i
didn't know i didn't see this day coming
i knew it was real we all turned down
chick-fil-a when we were doing
palm beach on palm beach i'll be great
i got stevie i don't think there's a
great restaurant stevie it's like [ __ ]
on the road
no he's not dude he's healthy
you're not paying attention he's not
dude and you know i have that problem
when people
eat yeah we eat so loud i was like bro
you're gonna eat those chips like that
during the day
she went through all he went through
three bags of doritos
he did not go yeah he all went through
no no no that was all the pretzels no he
wasn't he's all eminem
he he would do it in the back and then
he ate all the eminence yep
he gets the sodas yeah you pay attention
stevie
he's like dude two days i'll get off
diet for two days he goes nuts
but look at his body that's true but
he's eating because he's eating like
hard-boiled eggs during the week
that's the thing he goes hard for two
days but the rest of the month is super
clean
yeah so he could get away with cheat
meals do that
yeah we can't so so okay you can't cheat
at home so then we'll chill
we'll have a cheap cheap meal in palm
beach and palm beach
one just one just one yeah always if
it's one
there's not great food out there i mean
well people will send me like some
restaurants really
yeah we'll see what else you got
just one more it's your boy brian t city
uh he did something he modified his jeep
wait i'll show it to you right now
you supercharged it supercharged yeah
what a jeep
craftworks supercharger yeah
can it burn out though yeah
how crazy that's insane you know oh my
gosh dude
chappelle oh my god it's time it was
recent
you can hear the freaking blow-off valve
too
i wouldn't do that in it i get a little
scared of that stuff
damn dude this [ __ ] is badass i didn't
know that was possible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
that's you got to control that thing
though in a jeep
yeah those giant wheels burning out like
that that's
crazy that's so dope all right
that's all we got boys that's it and
that's it man all right [ __ ] all right
well the screw who is in palm beach
florida this week
thursday friday saturday bringing the
new years with the boys
the new year's tickets are sold out but
the other shows tickets still available
west palm beach uh palm beach improv
december 31st through january 2nd
then san marcos texas end of the month
january 29th through the 30th
with us very special guest and we're
right outside austin
we're outside san antonio san marcos
texas i cannot wait to get to texas
i know it's gonna be so much fun yes
can't wait january 29th through the 30th
get your tickets now tfatkay.com
all think boy gear think boy smiley
stuff they're gonna restock i know a lot
of sliders are sold out
but uh think boy.com for think boy
smiley sweats
hoodies tees hats they restocked the
tie-dye
uh and they restocked the hats too
thickboy.com that's it man
all right see you kids wednesday we out
yep